Google I/O
19 May 2010
Android
Casting a Wide Net: How to Target All Android
Devices
>>Justin Mattson: So good afternoon, everyone.
Thanks, everyone, for coming.
My name is Justin Mattson. I'm a developer
advocate, working at Google, where I have
been for the last about four years. And for
the last two years of that, I have been working
on the Android project, which is hopefully
what all you are here to hear me speak about.
And so the last two years on Android has been
really exciting, really crazy.
I expect it to get crazier and more exciting
as time goes on because that's all that happened.
And part of that excitement and craziness
has been the fact that if we go back two years
ago, Android was a software development kit
and an emulator.
Fast forward two years to today, and you can
go out on the show floor and see around 50
devices from a variety of manufacturers, running
on a variety of carriers around the world.
What that means is we have had an explosion
in the number of form factors and screens
and configurations that are out there, which
is really awesome, because Android has become
the optimal device for millions and millions
of users across the world.
Millions and millions of users that you can
now reach as developers for Android.
The other side of that, of course, is a challenge.
These devices are different. They run different
versions of Android. They have different screens.
So how can you, as developers, meet this challenge?
And that's what we're here to talk about today.
So a little housekeeping before we really
get into the main goal. As with the other
sessions, we're using Wave to both take notes
as well as discuss the presentation as it's
going on. If you would like to participate
in the Wave in any of these capacities, please
go to tinyurl.com/iocasting or scan the QR
code but be quick about it because I have
to keep moving.
So as I was saying, there's a huge opportunity
out there to reach a very large number of
users. And in order to realize that opportunity,
you have to meet a challenge which is running
across all of these devices.
The good news I am here to tell you today
is that meeting that challenge is not that
hard.
So I want to go over a set of considerations,
as you are building your Android applications,
that will give you a strong foundation for
running well across all devices in the Android
universe today.
And when I think about this task, I think
about it in two vectors. The first vector
is screen or UI compatibility, so we will
talk about that first, and mainly that has
to deal with the way you are creating layouts
and drawables for your project. And underlying
the layouts and drawables that you will use
for your project is the resource system which
is the foundation to build on and what I'll
talk about first.
The second vector of compatibility that I
think about is API-level compatibility. So
this means what APIs are available to you
as a developer from the Android system.
So I'm not going to talk about specific APIs
that are or are not available, but I will
talk to you about how to figure out what you
have available and then how to adapt your
program behavior based on that.
And finally, a word about testing because
I am talking about running on many, many devices,
and testing is going to be essential.
But I am also do a little preview in saying
you don't have to have all of those devices.
In this first vector of screen or UI compatibility
that I am talking about I first need to talk
about the resource system.
Now, the resource system might be something
that many of you are familiar with but I really
want to cover this because it's essential
as the basis for building a compatible Android
application.
So the resource loading system is there to
help you out.
It is there to load the resources that are
most appropriate for the current device configuration
that your application is running on.
So the question is, how does it pick those
resources? It picks those resources based
on a number of qualifiers. And these qualifiers
you use to label your bundles of resources
so the system can find them.
So I will refer to these resources as bundles
of resources or directories that live within
the resource directory of your project interchangeably.
So the other thing to realize is that the
configuration of your device can change while
your application is running. And if so, the
system is going to restart your process in
order so that the resource system can provide
all the new graphics and strings and everything
that you need.
A resource configuration change might come
in a number of forms, and I will mention one
of those a little bit later.
So I mentioned resources are specified by
some qualifiers that correspond to attributes
of the configuration of your system. And what
I want to do is go through a few of these
that are really important for this first vector
of screen or UI compatibility.
The first qualifier is screen size. And what
do I mean when I say screen size? By screen
size, I mean actual physical dimension of
the screen that your application is running
on, not something like, say, screen resolution.
And types of resources that are most concerned
with screen size are typically things like
layouts, because if you have more physical
space on your screen, you may choose to include
different UI elements or arrange them in a
different way.
Now, for Android devices out there, there
are actually many, many different screen sizes.
Some differ only by a tenth of an inch, and
these small differences aren't all that consequential
most of the time. So Android asks you not
to consider every individual screen size but,
rather, different buckets. And by focusing
on this much smaller set of different buckets,
you will greatly simplify the task of pick
being layouts that make sense for these different
screens.
The second qualifier to talk about is screen
orientation. You might also think of it as
aspect ratio.
So this is, is your screen wider or taller?
And pretty obviously, you know, the types
of resources that are concerned with this
are layouts. Sometimes drawable resources
like images that you will include, but more
often than not, layouts.
And I mentioned before that the configuration
of a system can change while your application
is running. Orientation is one of those configuration
parameters that is actually pretty likely
to change. And who has tried to stop the system
from killing their application when the orientation
changes?
Okay. I think more of you have probably tried
to do this, but don't do this. The system
is doing this for your own good. Because otherwise,
you have to figure out what are all the different
resources that you should load.
And so a change in screen orientation might
be triggered by a hardware change, like a
user flips out a keyboard on the G1 or the
Droid, or it might be the result of an accelerometer
event. You know, the sensors detect that the
screen orientation has changed.
And then when your app restarts, it gets this
opportunity to load the optimized layout for
the new configuration. So don't disable it.
Work with it, not against the system. The
system is probably going to win.
And the third qualifier I want to talk about
is screen density, which is the other attribute
of a screen that we are interested in. And
quite simply, density is the number of pixels
per whatever unit of measure you want to use.
Now, notably, the density qualifier works
differently than the previous two qualifiers
that I mentioned. Instead of being an exact-match
system, the density qualifier system works
on inexact matches. The system attempts to
find a best fit for the existing configuration.
And for best fit, the Android system asks
to you construct three sets of resources at
this point, resources for low density, medium
density, and high density screens. And the
types of resources you are most apt to create
customized versions with are the drawable
resources, the images that are going to be
rendered to the screen.
And so what does "best fit" in this case mean?
Well, best fit was designed to mean the density
qualifier that is closest to the actual screen
density that the app is being run on, and
the one that the system thinks will look best.
When talking about this qualifier, it's important
to note a critical bug in Android 1.5 with
respect to this qualifier, and that is the
fact that Android 1.5, unlike the design says,
selects the first match for the density qualifier
instead of the best match.
So if you are running on a medium density
screen, this might be the bundle of drawables
that is selected by the system to be displayed,
and then the system is going to scale all
of these. And if they are high density resources,
it will have to down sample.
So this is quite simply a bug, but then you
would ask, well, what is the order of resources
in the bundle? And this is determined by the
way the packaging tool packaged up the actual
application binary. And what the packaging
tool puts in the binary first is going to
be determined by the order in which the host
operating system of the packaging tool listed
the resources directory to it.
Now, unfortunately, different operating systems
list things differently. And it's not actually
even guaranteed that two runs on the same
operating system will produce the same results.
So the take-away here is that if you provide
these customized resources and support Android
1.5, the way that the density qualifier works
is completely indeterminate.
There is a way out of this problem which is
going to bring us to the version qualifier.
So before we go over how you can use the version
qualifier to fix the previous issue, let me
describe how it works.
And why you might care about it.
So independently of the great things it can
do to work around this other bug, the version
qualifier is most useful if you are trying
to adapt to different styles presented by
different versions of the operating system.
So between Android 1.6 and 2.0, for example,
the default look of icons on the home screen
changed from being sort of three dimensional,
as you can see on the right, as opposed -- and
went to being more flatter, more one dimensional
in 2.0, as you can see on the left.
And also, over time, you might imagine that
some sort of layout conventions change as
well, so you might decide to include custom
layouts and custom drawables for later or
earlier versions of the system.
Now, similar to the way the density qualifier
works, the version qualifier uses a best match
approach that is basically an inequality.
And the inequality says the best match will
be the version qualifier that is closest to
my own without exceeding it. So if you are
running on Android 2.0, which is version 5
of the operating system, and it sees a version
3 directory and nothing higher between three
and five, it will consider that a match. But
if there's a version 6 directory, that will
not be a match since it exceeds the current
SDK version of the system it is running on.
Now, two more small items before we talk about
how you can use this to work around the density
qualifier problems, is that the version qualifier
has bugs of its own.
So on Android 1.5 through 2.0, the version
qualifier does exact matching instead of inexact
matching. So Android 1.6, which is version
4 of the operating system, will not consider
the V3 directory a match. It will look only
for V4 or, of course, an unqualified resource
directory.
The second thing to be aware of is Android
2.0 thinks -- The resource system in Android
2.0 thinks that it's version 6.
So 2.0.1 which actually is version 6 also
thinks it's version 6. So for the resource
system, essentially version 5 never happened.
Now, happily, 2.0.1 and above, these bugs
are fixed. Everything works great.
So with these caveats in mind, how can we
get to our goal of having the right assets
selected for Android 1.5 and the medium density
screens that it runs on?
So we can do this. Or this is the beginning
of the solution, anyway. We have our medium
density resources and we know Android 1.5
is only ever going to run on a medium density
screen. We will have our medium density resources
and suffix them with V3.
So we know for sure this directory is going
to be picked by Android 1.5 now.
And actually, were it not for these two bugs
that I was just talking about, we'd be done.
But now there's an issue because version 4
and version 5 of the platform are not going
to select this directory, and with the structure
that I have listed here, they actually will
then use the low density or the high density
resources. In order to get around this, we
need to make a copy of the medium density
resources.
And as long as our medium density resources
are actually the same across all of the versus
of the platform, we're done. If you want to
include more customized resources for different
versions, it gets a little more complicated.
I am not going to go over that, but applying
the rules and caveats that I have described
here makes it pretty straightforward.
So unfortunately, to support optimized drawables
across all versions of the platform, you need
some resource duplication that's going to
inflate the size of your application package.
But that should give you a pretty complete
overview of the parts of the resource system
that you need to consider for this first vector
of UI or screen compatibility that I have
been talking about.
And now that we understand that, I want to
move on and build on that and talk about how
some specific types of resources are handled.
The specific type that I want to cover is
image resources, because a large part of many
people's applications out there involve images.
So it's important first to understand what
Android is trying to do with image resources,
and what the resource system is trying to
accomplish.
And that goal is that images -- bitmaps that
you include should be displayed as the same
physical size across all devices out there,
regardless of the screen configuration.
And this is great, because that means if you
define your image view to take a certain number
of density independent pixels, the system
is going to take care of all this math and
everything for you to figure out how many
actual pixels on the screen that view to take
up.
Now, a secondary consideration is whether
or not you want to include optimized resources
for every density bucket that's out there.
And for some types of images, this may not
actually be necessary.
If you have low-complexity things, like a
square or a circle or something like that
that's going to scale pretty well, it might
not be worth the extra application package
size.
But for other images that have a greater deal
of complexity or convey information based
on one or two pixels, it's really going to
be worth it to you to include optimized versions
and take that extra time in the prebuild process.
And to illustrate that, I want to walk through
how the system might handle scaling in this
case.
So let's say I've included this nice image
resource, very sophisticated and pretty, along
with my application package.
So I've got a smiley face, and I've rendered
him here on my representative medium-density
pixel grid.
Let's say this is the only resource that I've
include- -- the only version of this resource
that I've included with my application.
But what happens if then the application is
actually run on a low-density screen?
So in the middle here, I have a low-density
pixel grid.
And what I've done is overlaid the medium-density
pixels on it, and then tried to make some
guesses about the pixels that would be chosen
to be colored in.
This is essentially your sampling algorithm;
right?
So you can see the choices that I've made
here with my pretty simplistic sampling algorithm.
While they still convey the overall character
of the image, there's a significant loss of
fidelity.
And the other thing I want to do is select
a slightly different sampling algorithm.
And you can see that the fidelity lost here
is actually much greater.
Now, neither of these really represent what
the system does.
But the point that I want to get across is
that what sort of fidelity is retained is
highly dependent on the sophistication of
the sampling algorithm, and also that even
with the best of intentions, there's only
so much that the system can do with a limited
number of pixels.
And, finally, the other part of this is that
you can see that parts of this image, like
the curves of the face or the nose that are
dependent on just a couple of pixels are the
ones that have been impacted most greatly.
Whereas the sides of the face and, you know,
the ears have more or less retained their
character across, you know, all decisions
here, 'cause they're dependent on a greater
number of pixels to convey information.
So that's what will happen if you don't, you
know, interfere with the system and the way
it loads images in any way.
It will, you know, rescale these things for
you.
But let's say you want to manipulate what
the system does by default.
Well, are you really sure that you want to
do this?
You probably shouldn't do this.
You know, please, unless you're really, really
sure, just let the system do what was it was
designed to do and help you out.
But if you must, let's talk about breaking
the rules.
So the first thing to understand of how to
break the rules is what the rules are by default.
So by default, when resources are being loaded,
you -- and you grab a BitmapFactory object,
for example, and say, create a bitmap out
of this resource or this URI or something,
and provide no BitmapFactory options object,
the BitmapFactory options will be set to their
defaults, which are something like this.
And we're concerned with two of the options.
The input density and the input target density.
So the input density is the density that the
system believes the resource was designed
for.
So if it plucks a resource out of the medium-density
drawable folder, it's going to assume that
this was intended for medium density.
And then the end target density is the density
of the screen that this input is targeted
to be displayed on.
So, typically, the screen on the phone.
And then whether or not the system is going
to scale this when it's rendered on the screen
is dependent on the ratio between these two
values.
So, obviously, if you want to get around this,
what you can do is provide your own -- your
own bitmap options object and set the in density
equal to the in target density equal to the
density of the screen that you're running
on.
And, basically, this will help you in those
couple of situations -- and there really aren't
very many -- where you want to override the
system's default behavior and, you know, really
render your image pixel for pixel.
And the result in my previous example here
was that I wouldn't have gotten any of these
scaling effects, but it's going to take up
a larger portion of the screen because I'm
taking up the same number of larger pixels,
which, as I said, generally isn't what you
want to do.
So Nine-Patches.
Who's used Nine-Patches?
Who wants to use Nine-Patches and doesn't
understand them?
Okay.
A few people.
And so Nine-Patches are a really powerful
type of image resource.
And, basically, what they do is take your
base image resource and layer some information
on top of it.
And the purpose of these things is so you
can include fewer drawables in your package.
Because the bit of information that you're
layering on top instructs the system how to
scale and manipulate this image so that it
can fit larger or smaller sizes than it's
currently designed for.
So I'd really like to go over these.
Unfortunately, my desire to do this is not
sufficient to allow me to do so, because I
don't have time.
So we're going to go through it really quick.
Pay attention.
Nine-Patches.
So that's how they work.
They're really great.
You should look into them.
And I'm -- will try to get these slides that
I didn't talk about at all up as soon as possible
with greater descriptions so they will be
useful.
Okay.
So I -- really, I spent a lot of time on these
graphics, because I'm not a graphic designer.
And I had to cut them out.
So I've been talking about images and bitmaps
and things like that.
And so now I want to step back a bit and talk
about drawables in general.
So the bitmap resources that you include with
your package are one of the things that's
drawn to the screen.
But drawables are a broader class and are,
quite simply, anything that knows how to render
itself to the screen.
So in talking about drawables, I want to bring
forward some classes that can help you out
when you're writing your application, can
help you draw a user interface that is better
optimized to the screen that you're running
on, allows you to have a smaller application
package size, reduce the amount of work that
you'll need to do when creating your package,
and generally make everyone happy.
So this is, you know, sort of a tips and tricks
section.
And the first type of drawable that I want
to talk about is shapes.
Maybe some of you are thinking, shapes.
My God.
They're so basic.
Why do we want to talk about shapes?
Well, shapes are great, because they're classes
that know how to draw simple graphics primitives
to the screen, like a circle or a rectangle
or the special rectangle, a square.
And what's great about these is that you can
use them in a couple of ways.
First of all, I've unzipped developers' applications
before to find that they've included a number
of drawables which are merely colored circles
or colored squares, things like this, and
for no reason, they made their application
larger, when they should have just used shape
drawable.
And the second thing is that it's pretty common
to want to form a composite type of drawable
where you're using some basic shape and then
actually some custom drawable, maybe like
a company logo that you want to include on
some different colored fields or something
like this.
So instead of having to go through the work
at the beginning to create these, you can
use shapes at run time to draw great-looking
versions on the screen.
And this is really facilitated by the shape
classes, because they have this handy draw
method to help you in building a custom view.
And if you were going to build a custom view,
like, one that rendered my little Google I/O
logo there on a green rectangle, you might
do it something like this.
So the first thing that this view class is
doing is creating a new rectangle shape.
And then in the constructor, I'm grabbing
this logo from my applications resources.
And then when it comes time to actually draw
my view, render it to screen, I'm first telling
the shape what size it needs to be.
And then handing it the Canvas that my view
was handed by the drawing system.
And then I'll simply draw my logo on top of
that one it's finished.
And the result is that I didn't need to include
my logo on a green background and a red background
and a blue background and, you know, textured
and everything like that.
I was able to include just the unique bit
and then handle these generic operations in
code at run time.
Another drawable type that can be really useful
on this vector of screen compatibility is
the scale drawable.
And the scale drawable's a wrapper around
another drawable that allows you more customized
control of the way that drawable grows and
changes as the screen grows or the aspect
ratio changes.
This can be particularly useful in places
where one dimension of the underlying drawable
is much more important than the other dimension.
So for this, think things like a horizontal
progress bar, the horizontal is actually much
more important, and you'd like to grow that
out as the screen gets wider, but you don't
necessarily want to make it a whole bunch
taller.
Rather, you'd like to take that vertical screen
space and do something more interesting with
it.
Similarly, dividers of vertical or horizontal
varieties have a dimension that is certainly
more important than the other.
So, basically, you know, anyplace where one
dimension is more important than the other
is one where a scale drawable can help you
out in making the UI look better as well as
reducing the number of actual drawable resources
that you need to include.
The next one I want to talk about is the level
list drawable, which I think is a rather clever
little beast.
And so the level list drawable is a composite
of other drawables that you include in your
package.
And what it does is logically groups these
resources or other drawables into one element.
And part of what this is doing is separating
out your presentation from your implementation.
So your implementation can be concerned with
figuring out what state your drawable should
be in, and then the level list will figure
out, based on that state, what the exact presentation
should be.
An example that, you know, is really straightforward
of using these is a status meter of some variety.
So imagine you have a battery meter and you
have drawables for different charge levels,
but you don't have one for every charge level
from 0 to 100%.
And the drawable itself should just figure
out which of -- which of the drawables that
are its children it should pick to draw to
the screen.
And your code should just be concerned with
setting the status of that drawable so it
can figure out how to draw itself.
There are some other kind of less-conventional
uses for this.
You might use it for weather conditions or
perhaps if you're trying to pick what a drawable
should look like on different UI themes, because
there are a couple different UI themes out
there for Android devices.
And if you're using some of these less-natural
scenarios for level lists, you can define
constants in your code that are going to make
the code much more readable and logical in
terms of setting what the level means and
what it stands for.
So the goal of this drawable is really to
make your code easier and more readable and
logically separate the concerns of presentation
from the actual code implementation.
And I want to walk through a quick example
of using this, because I really do like level
list and think it's, you know, rather clever.
So let's say that I have an application where
I want to provide details of -- you know,
details for a sports game that's going to
happen.
And one thing that I'm worried about is what
the weather is going to be like.
And I want to render this attribute on the
screen.
Now, logically, this part of the screen is
always just weather condition, what it's going
to be like.
My code just wants to think about weather
condition, set the condition, let the UI figure
out the rest.
So I've got my level list here defined in
XML which has a number of items.
So the items have two attributes.
They refer to a drawable resource.
In this case, it was just bitmaps.
And then they also have this max level parameter.
And this is the maximum value that the level
list is set to for which this drawable is
appropriate.
For example, here, I'm basically saying if
the chance of rain is between zero and 10%,
I want to put the chance slight up there.
If the chance is between 10 and 40, okay,
I'll say -- you know, I'll say the chance
is sort of good.
So then if I want to use this in my code,
it looks something like this.
And it looks really simple, which is awesome.
I've exported some of the switch statement
complexity that I might otherwise have to
this nice markup language that I don't have
to clutter my code with.
And I can even let my designers reconfigure
this for me, and I don't have to worry about
it.
So I'm just finding the view that corresponds
to my weather condition here.
And then I'm setting the image level.
And maybe I'll get the image level, which
is the probability of rain, from some Web
service out there.
And if you'd like -- if you'd like suggestions
on how to do this best, make sure to attend
the first Android session tomorrow, which
I saw a preview of and is actually really
awesome.
But, anyway, so I'll call out to my Web service
and, you know, get the probability back, and
then the UI element will figure out how to
display itself.
So if there's a good chance of rain, it might
look something like this.
You know, if the chance of rain is pretty
low, it might look as such.
And then -- but I could also use this for
something less conventional.
I could use it for the sports teams here,
to control what icons.
And for this, I would do something just like
defining logical constants that correspond
to the sports teams and then setting those
to be -- correspond to max level in my level
list attributes.
Oh, and a special thanks to the -- the open
clip art project, which has some great public
domain images that saved me probably a day
of work trying to create a cloud with a sun
behind it.
I'm not a graphic artist.
So talking about resources, talking about
images and drawables, these are the main components
of what you'll need to think about when you're
thinking about cross-screen compatibility
or this UI compatibility factor that I've
been talking about.
So there are a number of things in the system
to help you out, you know, the resource system,
and also a simplification of the universe,
collapsing the different screens and different
-- collapsing the different screen configurations
into a handful instead of the myriad that
are actually on the 50 devices out there.
But of course your application isn't just
UI.
There's probably some code that drives that
And the code that drives that UI is going
to run on different versions of the Android
operating system.
Today, we have three major versions out there.
We have Android 1.5, 1.6, and 2.1.
And I'm here to tell you that multiple versions
are the norm, not the exception.
Sorry.
So I think that we'll probably always have
at least two major versions of the Android
other there.
But this isn't such a terrible thing.
And it's actually not that hard to deal with.
So let's go over how we deal with this diversity,
with this API diversity.
And so basically what I'm going to talk about
here is detection.
And after the condition of the environment
has been detected, you have any number of
different ways that you can deal with that
change.
Or not that change, but deal with that situation.
Don't worry.
The API level isn't one of those things that
will change while your application is running.
That would be really bad.
So the basics -- So there are two types of
API changes that we're going to consider.
One is when whole new classes enter or leave
the API, and the other is when individual
methods get appended or removed or changed.
But the basic strategy for dealing with both
of these situations is the same, which is
to insert yourself into the class loading
and verification chain of command so that
you can intercept any errors, realize what
the error means, and then deal with it in
your code appropriately.
And so for dealing with class-level changes,
what we're going to walk through is using
some static methods and members which are
basically going to poke the class loading
system and say, "Tell me if something" -- you
know, "Tell me if this item isn't available."
Then we'll catch any error that that system
throws to us, and adapt the behavior appropriately.
And so by using the -- a secondary class with
some static methods, we'll avoid this kind
of messy probing where we call class forename
and type out the whole name, which we might
mistype and get a false positive on and all
sorts of messy things.
The downside of this, of course, is that we
need more classes of either top-level classes
or inner classes to help us out.
And to deal with this, you might have just
a host of inner classes in sort of whatever
class host your detection code, or you might
sequester them all in one package where they're
kind of out of the way of the rest of your
project.
And one of these detector classes might look
something like this.
So I've got my class here called canary.
For anyone not familiar, canaries used to
be used in coal mining to detect if dangerous
gases were building up.
So unfortunately for the canary, it would
typically die, but the miners would come out
alive.
So my digital canary is going to have a private
static member that is of type whatever I'm
looking for, whatever the new class is.
And then I've got the static method try new
class that tries to create a new instance
of this class.
Now, there are a couple of different ways
that I can do this.
I wouldn't necessarily have to create a new
instance.
There are some different ways to skin this
cat.
But this is the one that I'm, you know -- the
one that I'm fond of and going to choose for
this case.
So how does canary integrate with the rest
of my code?
So if I've got my activity here, what I'm
going to do is have this Boolean that tells
me whether the canary is available.
After I made these slides, I realized I probably
should have said canary alive or not, and
that sort of goes with the rest of the metaphor.
If canary is available and alive, I'll do
one thing.
And if it's not, I'll do another.
So the first thing that I'm going to do is
have my check APIs method here, which is going
to call this static method in my canary class.
And when it does this, the class loader for
Android is for the first time going to pull
canary into memory, look at it, and go, "Do
you work on this system?"
And if it does, you know, my code's going
to proceed, and I'll say the canary's available
and alive.
But if the class loader looks at it and says,
"Wait a second, we don't have that.
It's going to freak out and throw an error
and say we can't load this class."
I'm going to catch that error and note that
the canary is not available and also put in
the log that the canary's not available, which
will hopefully help with debugging later on
if I find some odd application behavior and
I see this in the log, I'll know that the
compatibility mode code had been invoked.
So this will help me deal with when whole
new classes come in or go out of the API.
But sometimes the API-level changes are a
bit more subtle than that.
Sometimes they're just new methods or maybe
even just changed method signatures.
And I think this case is a little bit trickier
to deal with.
But the same basic, you know, two-phased strategy
of detect and deal with is still being used.
So in the detection phase, I have the choice
of using reflection to see if a given class
has a method available.
Or I can take the step to make my code version-aware,
which means I'll have some bit of code that
has, you know, the lookup table that says,
in this version of the OS, I have these -- you
know, I have these APIs available.
In this version, I have these APIs available,
et cetera, et cetera.
And then that code can just look at the build
version number.
The downside of this, of course, is that this
is pretty brittle.
It's open to human error.
And it means when new versions come out, you're
going to have to scramble and update this
code.
So once we've detected whether or not something
is available, you know, how are we going to
create a class that works in this environment?
Well, one way is that we can call a questionable
method through using reflection.
And this is going to result in fewer classes,
because then my detection code can also operate
on these underlying classes and I won't throw
any verification errors.
The other option is to use some sort of factory
pattern which will, you know, figure out availability
and then based on that, load the appropriate
class that implements an interface that only
touches methods that are available on this
version of the platform.
So reflection is going to give me fewer classes.
The factory method will give me more classes
but is somewhat cleaner in the implementation
because I'm only calling through to actual
class methods as opposed to using reflection
to make the calls, which, again, messier dependent
on typing, dependent on typing on the keyboard
correctly.
And so what I'm going to walk through here
is doing this just solely with reflection.
It's the method I'd recommend and the method
that I prefer.
So this time, all the action is going to focus
on my canary class.
So I've got my canary.
And as I said before, there are a couple different
ways to do the detection phase.
And I'm using a different one here.
So I have my private member, which is now
a method, the actual method type in Java.
And then I'm using a static initializer block.
So the static initializing block is going
to run when the class is first loaded into
memory.
And in this case, what I'm doing is calling
getdensity.
Or, well, so my getdensity member is going
to be assigned the getdensity method of the
Canvas class if it's available.
And, incidentally, this method is only available
on Android 1.6 and above, because that, there
was only one density in the world, medium
density, on the G1.
But if not, the class loading system is going
to throw an error, which, again, I'll log
and implicitly detect by leaving getdensity
null.
So, then, to actually use this in code, like
I said, all the action is on canary this time.
And canary is going to expose this interface
that my other classes are going to call through
to.
And so I realize in this slide I left this
extraneous "hasDensity" member.
So please just ignore that.
So in my getdensity method that canary has,
I'll first see, all right, did I find that
getdensity the method of Canvas was available?
And if so, I'll just return the result from
that.
But I'll invoke that method using Reflection,
which means regardless of the system that
I'm actually running on, canary can be loaded,
because I'm never calling Canvas.getdensity.
If I called Canvas.getdensity directly, when
canary was loaded on Android 1.5, there would
be an error thrown.
So I've met my goal of fewer classes but somewhat
messier calling syntax here.
But if canary isn't available, I'll perform
some default behavior.
In this case, default behavior is pretty easy
to figure out, because it is just to say that
I'm on a medium-density device, because Android
1.5, only medium density.
What you may choose to do with your applications
instead is to either disable -- disable whole
sections of functionality or to try to run
in some degraded mode when you don't have
access to APIs that you would like.
And so by using these, you know, somewhat
clever, somewhat not clever tricks with Reflection,
you'll be able to detect the environment that
you're running in and then at run time, adapt
your behavior accordingly and meet this goal
of having -- you know, the second vector of
compatibility, this version-level API compatibility.
So now having talked about the two vectors,
I just want to say a couple words on testing.
Testing is always important for any code that
you write.
But certainly if you're writing tricky code
that uses Reflection or providing different
resources, you want to verify that all of
this works properly.
And there's really nothing better than actually
testing your application.
It allows you to verify that the UI that you've
designed for different screen resolutions
and different screen sizes and densities is
working properly, and also check that the
API compatibility code that we just went through
is working as expected.
And the great thing is that you can do pretty
much all of this checking on the Android emulator
itself.
So for some of you, you will be writing applications
that access bits of hardware that the emulator
doesn't, well, emulate.
Maybe it's the Bluetooth stack or -- or using
Wi-Fi or something like that.
In which case, you probably will need a bit
of hardware to actually do your testing.
Oh, my God, he admitted you might need hardware
for testing.
So -- But the happy news there is that you
don't need every piece of hardware in the
world.
So as I've said before, the Android system
tries to simplify the view of the device universe,
particularly with respect to screens, into
some different buckets. So at most what you
need is hardware from each of these different
buckets. And there really aren't that many
buckets out there. So no need to run out and
buy all 50 phones that you see on the show
floor, although I I'm sure the OEMs would
love it if you did. So support our OEMs.
So I hope in this presentation you have seen
that supporting all these different device
models that will reach millions and millions
of users is not a Herculean task but one that
is imminently within your reach.
There are these cluster of considerations
to think about while you are building your
application, and if you take these to mind
as you are writing your code and designing
your resources, you are going to end up with
an application that looks great across all
those devices in the hands of millions of
users.
So with that, I'll turn it over to questions.
Again, here is the URL for the live Wave,
and the QR code which I will leave up for
just slightly longer this time.
Okay.
And I'm going to try to switch over to Wave
here,
and see what we have in terms of questions.
If there are live questions, please go to
the microphones and we'll try to multiplex
in some efficient way.
How to target devices like aPad?
Android Pad. I haven't heard of the Android
Pad. I don't think it exists. So -- Sorry?
>>> (Speaking off mic)
>>Justin Mattson: So someone is talking about
the lobby of Building 43, and I believe you
are referring to what we call the Mega Phone,
which is, if you haven't seen pictures, of
the life size, kind of, Nexus Ones.
The answer is there is no aPad but I can actually
answer this question for you which is to say
use all the things which we have been talking
about here.
If you think about this, anything that is
sort of a tablet-sized device just has a different
screen configuration. And we have the resources
in the system for you to be able to deal with
this.
So I am going to go to a live question over
there.
>>> Yeah, one of the things that I ran into
in trying handle the rotation, for example,
was I have an application that solves puzzles,
and it takes a while to do that and it does
it in a thread in the background and is constantly
showing "updating the screen." So the -- when
the -- if you do the normal let the application
-- or let the system kill the activity and
restart it, you lose your UI context that
the background thread is trying to access
through the handler. How do you deal with
that?
>>Justin Mattson: So -- But you are still
preserving your thread running in the background,
I assume.
>>> That's correct.
>>Justin Mattson: Okay; great.
So you are doing that, and before I answer
your question I want to talk about how you
are probably doing that, which many, many
devs I have talked to aren't aware of. And
so that's this great call-back called onRetainNonConfigurationInstance
So if you are handling a configuration change
and you have got long-running stuff, solving
a puzzle in the background, you can shove
that running thread into the object that is
passed along to onRetainNonConfigurationInstance,
and that thread will keep running and keep
spinning away while the orientation or something
else is changing and allow you to not do all
these nasty tricks, like storing things in
static members.
So to answer your question, how do you deal
with a lost UI context, and I don't think
there is any magic answer here. You basically
need some bit on that thread that you can
set on that thread to say UI unavailable.
And then when the UI comes back, what you
want to perhaps have is -- so one way perhaps
that you want to structure your puzzle solver
thread is to actually have a looper of its
own, and have that looper be able to receive
the message from the main UI thread when it
comes back.
So have something in "on create" that will
be able to get to that handler and send it
a message. And that handler is something that
you might want to store in that nonconfiguration
instance object. So then the thread will get
the signal, okay, this is available again,
and I can go ahead and update the UI.
>>> Okay. Thank you.
>>Justin Mattson: So let's go over here, on
the other side for a question.
>>> So I have a question. If you are targeting
the other way, if you actually don't want
to support all devices, are there any targeting
options, for example, in the manifest other
than the version, the Android version?
>>Justin Mattson: So I actually had to forget
that I don't have to repeat the question.
You are on a mic.
So the answer there is a little bit that you
can do. One is that you can say what screen
sizes you support. So you can, for example,
opt out of small screen sizes.
Now, if you do something like opt out of large
screen sizes, you don't actually opt out of
them because what the system can do is say,
okay, were you designed for a normal size
screen. Well, I will just letterbox you because
I run you in the context of this larger size
screen and you are going to perform like you
are expected to.
You know, conversely, with small screens we
can't take a large interface and cram it into
a small screen nearly as well.
So there are a limited number of options here,
and I guess I would really hope that the focus
is on bringing Android applications to all
the users out there. I certainly understand
that sometimes not all devices can be supported
from the beginning. And you may be left in
a situation where you will just have to do
run time detection and say I'm sorry, I don't
support your configuration.
And the other thing to be aware of with this
is that this ability to filter and target
is actually at the Android market level. So
the screen's attribute that I was talking
about, for example, is completely ignored
by the package system. So it won't refuse
to install something that doesn't say that
it supports the screen. It will install it
and then try to run it and see what happens.
So it's just something to be aware of, that
if you are delivering an app through your
own Web site or something like that, you may
not have that same sort of protection that
market affords you.
>>> Thanks.
>>Justin Mattson: Sure.
So I want to go back to a question on the
Wave.
How will future versions of Android address
fragmentation?
Well, so first of all, let's define fragmentation.
And so fragmentation is when the same version
of Android runs differently across different
hardware. And so to date, I haven't really
seen that many instances of fragmentation.
I suspect the asker of this question was saying
-- was asking how will we address the fact
that Android runs on devices that aren't the
same?
So the answer is we are not going to stop
Android from running on different devices.
Running on different devices is great. It
allows people to put different phones, all
sorts of things out there that meet the end
users' needs. The end users want different
types of devices. They want different configurations
because they meet their needs better.
So what Android already does and will continue
to do for us and try to do better and better
as time goes on is allow you to understand
the environment in which you are operating
and adapt to it appropriately, and provide
tools where it can.
For example, where I was talking about imagery
source scaling before. This is something provided
by the system so that it's easier to run on
different screen densities out there. And
where we can provide these things that will
help developers out, we will implement them.
So --
>>> (speaking off mic).
>>Justin Mattson: Mine is not being refreshed.
So I don't know if that answered the questioner's
question. If they are here, raise your hand.
And if it didn't, we'll....
Okay.
Okay. Let's do another live question over
here.
>>> I just want to point out that there's
a better way to handle the case -- or detect
the case where a method has been added on
a newer version of Android.
>>Justin Mattson: I'm sorry, to detect where
what has been added?
>>> The case where a method has been added
on the new version.
>>Justin Mattson: Sure.
>>> You can actually use the same way that
you detected a new class has been added. You
can just catch the verifier --
>>Justin Mattson: Mm-hmm.
>>> I use that in Hello Android third edition
when I went to support multi-touch and also
not multi-touch.
>>Justin Mattson: Mm-hmm.
>>> So I just had a class which extended move
events. And if you were on an old Android,
it got a verify error which you could catch.
>>Justin Mattson: Sure. And yes, that's another
way that you can do it, and certainly I was
hoping to bring out a number of different
ways to skin this cat that if different people
have different exact use cases and situations,
they can choose from the one that makes the
most sense for them.
But, yeah, that's a good point. You can use
very much the same method as for the whole
new class to do a method.
Okay. So last question. So raise your hand
if you -- So raise your hand if you want me
to answer the first question up here or take
another audience question.
So question up here, raise your hand.
Audience question.
Audience wins.
You, sir.
>>> Me.
>>Justin Mattson: Yes.
>>> So mostly from listening you to talk,
it seems like you were addressing graphical
objects.
>>Justin Mattson: Mm-hmm.
>>> You know, icons, drawables, images, Nine-Patches,
things like that.
I have an issue where an app that I wrote
for the G1 -- I actually didn't write it for
the G1. It runs properly on the G1, displays
an edit text view properly on the G1, but
on the Android it actually, it collapses it
and it cuts it off, and things just aren't
lining up.
So I was wondering if you have any advice
or hints for not graphical objects but regular
UI objects.
>>Justin Mattson: Sure. So the edit text is
in some sense just a drawable object itself.
Now, this actually is also sort of the first
question up here, what if things behave differently
on different devices. And so if things behave
differently on different devices, it's a bug.
Report that bug.
Report it loudly, if you need to.
>>> Okay.
>>Justin Mattson: But report it.
>>> I am reporting it.
>>Justin Mattson: Now, in your specific case,
are you perhaps defining the size of the text
that goes into the edit text in number of
pixels, PX?
>>> I would have to go back and look at my
XML file. I think I am defining it in terms
of DIP.
I recently went through my XML files and kind
of did a purge on PXs and replaced everything
with DIP. There may be a straggler out there
but I think it's all working off of DIP.
>>Justin Mattson: Then the answer is I am
not aware of that bug, and so report it on
the forums and wherever and we will pick it
apart.
So the specific issue, though, I am talking
about is if you define things on PX, there
was a bug in at least one version of Android
that ran on Droid where the number of pixels
that correspond to a PX was incorrect. And
so any text that you defined in terms of PX
would render incorrectly, but I think it's
only fair because we tell you not to use PX,
and use DIP, DP or SP.
>>> And just to clarify one of the very first
questions. There actually is a device out
there called the aPad. This came out on some
of the gadget sites about a week or two ago
-- about a week ago. If you Google for Android
and aPad, there is a Chinese knock-off company
out there who is selling a generic tablet
device running Android 1.5.
>>Justin Mattson: Does it look cool?
>>>It looks pretty freaking cool.
>>Justin Mattson: Okay. I'll have to look
it up.
So we are over time, and they are going to
shoot me pretty soon, but thank you all for
coming and enjoy targeting all those devices
and the users that come along with them.
[ Applause ]